What are the learning outcomes of this course? At the conclusion of this class,
you will be able to do three primary things. First, you'll be able to design,
implement and evaluate and describe knowledge-based AIs. The design and
description of knowledge-based AI agent is really the first learning goal.
In order to be able to design an agent,
you need knowledge of the methods of knowledge-based AI. Second, you will also
be able to use these strategies to address practical problems. This learning
outcome addresses the second learning goal, where you will be able to
[INAUDIBLE] the relationship between AI agents and real world problems. Third,
you'll also be able to use the design of knowledge-based AI agents to reflect on
human cognition and vice versa. This addresses the fourth learning goal.